- [Instructor] Now,
we're going to talk about
one of the most famous conquerors
in all of human history,
and that is Alexander the Great.
But before talking about
all of the things that he conquered,
let's think about how he got started out
and in particular, how he's
able to consolidate control
over the empire that his father begins.
So, in the last video,
we saw that exiting the Peloponnesian War,
the Greeks were weak.
Sparta and its allies,
the Peloponnesian League,
they had won, but the Greeks
were ripe for being conquered.
And they end up being
conquered by Philip II,
King of Macedonia, and
he rules from Pella.
And shortly after he
becomes king, his son,
his first son, Alexander, is born.
And Alexander is the son that
Philip has with Olympias.
Olympias is the daughter
of the king of Molossia,
which makes her Molossian
and not Macedonian,
which is going to be
somewhat important later on
when Philip II dies.
But the early part of
Alexander's life is quite good
and he seems to be in favor
with his father, Philip II.
After all, Alexander seems like
a decent heir to the throne.
Early in his life, he gets from his father
what is arguably the best
tutor, for sure of the time,
probably the best tutor in
human history, in Aristotle.
And the way that his father convinces him
to tutor Alexander when Alexander's 13,
he tutors him from when Alexander
is about 13 to about 16,
is Philip destroys
Aristotle's village of Stagira
as he conquers Greece.
And Aristotle says, "Okay,
sure, I'll tutor your son.
"But in exchange for that, why
don't you rebuild my hometown
"and free all of the people
who had been enslaved
"after the town was conquered?"
And so, Philip agrees;
Alexander gets a great tutor.
There's also the stories of
how Alexander carried favor
with his father by taming
the famous horse Bucephalus,
who Alexander will
eventually ride into Asia
as he conquers the
Persian Empire and beyond.
And Philip, very proud of his young son
being able to conquer this
seemingly untamable horse,
as Philip conquers, as he conquers Greece,
Alexander is alongside him leading troops,
showing him to be a
capable military general,
a capable leader.
So, all seems to be working
out well for Alexander
until Philip takes what ends up being
his seventh and last wife.
Until then, Olympias was his favored wife.
And Olympias is a bit of a character,
at least from the point of historians.
And you should take all of
this with a grain of salt
because many of these
histories and these stories
were written hundreds of years later,
and so it's not clear how
much was a true account
versus how much was made up.
But beyond Olympias not being Macedonian,
she is from Molossia, she is
also, according to Plutarch,
part of the Cult of Dionysus
and she worships snakes
and potentially even sleeps with snakes,
which is really off-putting
to a lot of the Macedonians.
And so, when King Philip,
in around 337 or 338,
finds a Macedonian to marry
and her name is Cleopatra,
not the famous Cleopatra from history,
we'll talk about her
in a few hundred years,
but you see here, Philip II,
he takes his seventh wife.
I don't list them all here.
I only list Olympias here
who he marries in 357 BCE.
And then they have Alexander,
born Alexander III,
shortly thereafter the next year.
They also have another
daughter, Cleopatra.
Once again, not the Cleopatra
when people refer to it in history.
But then, around 337 or 338
BCE, he takes his seventh wife,
and this seventh wife
is also named Cleopatra.
She is Macedonian.
Philip renames her
Eurydice after his mother.
And so, you can imagine
this is already a little bit threatening.
Because, well, what if
this Cleopatra has a son?
And she eventually does have a son.
And now, that son would
be pure Macedonian,
as opposed to Alexander,
who is only half-Macedonian.
And this becomes quite pointed
at the wedding of Philip and Cleopatra,
the Macedonian Cleopatra,
in 337 or 338 BCE
when we have this account, and once again,
take all of this with a grain of salt.
This is an account by Plutarch
that was written 400 years later.
But Plutarch writes, "At
the wedding of Cleopatra,"
this is Cleopatra Eurydice,
this is the Macedonian
Cleopatra, the young one,
"whom Philip fell in
love with and married,
"she being much too young
for him, her uncle Attalus,"
and you see him on our
little family tree here,
this is Cleopatra's Uncle
Attalus, a Macedonian,
"her uncle Attalus in his drink
"desired the Macedonians
would implore the gods
"to give them a lawful
successor to the kingdom
"by his niece."
Let me underline that.
Give them a lawful
successor to the kingdom.
You might be saying,
"Wait, I thought Alexander
was a lawful successor?"
And Alexander's probably
thinking the same thing.
"This so irritated Alexander
"that throwing one of
the cups at his head,"
throwing it at Attalus' head,
"'you villain,' he said.
"'What, am I then a bastard?'
Then Philip," Alexander's dad,
"taking Attalus' part," so he
wouldn't take his son's side,
he takes the side of his in-laws,
"rose up and would have
run his son through,
"but by good fortune for them both,
"either his over-hasty rage,
or the wine he had drunk,
"made his foot slip, so that
he fell down on the floor.
"At which Alexander
reproachfully insulted over him:
"'See there,' said he, 'the
man who makes preparations
"'to pass out of Europe into Asia,
"'overturned in passing
from one seat to another.'"
So, if this account by
Plutarch is even vaguely true,
it shows this real tension that is forming
between Alexander and his father.
And it's of course being goaded on,
or likely to be goaded on,
by his mother, Olympias,
who was the primary wife for a little bit
but now she's being pushed aside
in favor of this Macedonian, Cleopatra.
And so she actually goes
into voluntary exile,
Alexander follows her, and
so things are quite tense.
And they really come to a boiling point,
or everything gets released
a year or two later,
when Olympias' other child,
Cleopatra, the other Cleopatra,
not Cleopatra Eurydice
and not the famous Cleopatra from history,
she gets married to Olympias' brother.
And so, she's marrying her uncle.
Many strange things happened
like this in the ancient world.
This is 336 BCE and this
is the famous wedding
where Phillip II is
assassinated by his bodyguard,
who was likely Phillip II's former lover.
But once Phillip II gets assassinated,
you could imagine that many people
are wanting to have a go at the throne,
in particular, Alexander,
aided by his mother, Olympias.
And so immediately, there
starts to be a consolidation
of power and the first
way to consolidate power
is to kill off all of the
folks who might threaten you.
And so Olympias and Alexander,
and many historians give
credit mainly to Olympias,
some say Alexander was
involved more or less,
but they go on a killing spree.
Europa is killed, Caranus is killed.
These are the children
of Cleopatra Eurydice.
At the time of this, we're
talking 336, 335 BCE,
they would have been toddlers.
They would have been two,
at most three years old.
They're being killed.
There are some accounts
that Cleopatra is killed
or she is forced to hang herself.
There's some accounts that
some combination of them
are burned alive.
Alexander goes after
Attalus, the famous uncle
who insulted him at the wedding
party only a few years ago.
He kills his cousin, Amyntus,
who might have had a claim
to the throne, other princes.
So this is this bloody, bloody period.
So even though sometimes people
glorify some of these rulers
like Alexander the Great, that
they unified all these people
and they pushed culture
throughout the world,
or however you want to talk about it,
they usually come to
power in very brutal ways.
And their conquering is also very brutal.
You really shouldn't romanticize,
oh let's conquer other people.
A war is ugly and when
there's multiple factions
coming to a throne, that is also ugly.
So, we're shortly after
Phillip II's death.
Alexander, with the help of his mother,
is able to consolidate
power within his family,
really secure his place
as the king of the Macedonian Empire.
And so the next thing
is to secure his hold
on the empire militarily
and you immediately
start having rebellions
to the North and West of Macedon.
And so, in particular, the Illyrians,
which is in modern-day Albania,
so this region right over here.
They start to revolt.
Alexander goes and makes a point
of sieging the pass at Peliam.
This is a very strategic
location but while he's there
with his military forces,
so while he's there
with his military forces, you can imagine
the other city-states of Greece,
in particular Athens and Thebes,
say hey now's our chance.
King Phillip is dead,
Alexander's out fighting
with the Illyrians,
let's rise up and regain our independence.
And many of them thought that Alexander
might have already died in the
previous military campaign.
And so you can imagine
they were very surprised
after Alexander took control
through a siege at Peliam,
and is able to come down
surprisingly quickly.
He really makes his soldiers march
hundreds of kilometers
in a matter of weeks,
to come down and put down the rebellion,
from his point of view, at Thebes.
And the Thebans refuse to stop rebelling
and so in retaliation, Alexander the Great
completely destroys Thebes,
this famous city of antiquity.
Only a few decades before this time,
the leading city-state in all of Greece.
And so he destroys Thebes,
he enslaves its people,
but that's what allows
him to essentially scare
the rest of the city-states
of Greece to come in line.
He hasn't conquered Sparta,
or his empire hasn't conquered
Sparta, that will happen soon
but the rest, it really
consolidates his power.
And now, we're talking 335 BCE,
he's ready to think about doing
what his father was planning
and going off and trying to conquer Asia.